eigentlich könnten wir bereits die
totenmesse feiern so apathisch so
gleichgültig wie wir der
klimaveränderung zu sehen
und die zeit verrinnt
seit jahrzehnten wissen wir um die
brutalen konsequenzen des klimawandels
die augen verschließen kann mit gutem
gewissen niemand mehr
und dennoch hörte niemand wie schnell
die uhr tickt
beim klimawandel bleibt uns nur noch
eine knappe wissenschaftlich erwiesene
frist bis zum ende dieses jahrzehnts
können wir noch die umkehr schaffen oder
wir verschlimmern alles ins
unermessliche das ist unsere deadline
das klingt wie eine letzte galgenfrist
zur rettung des planeten namik klein die
kanadische ikone der
globalisierungskritik spart in ihrem
neuen buch nicht mit drastik sie fordert
eine entscheidung zwischen
kapitalistischer wirtschaftsordnung oder
der finalen klimakatastrophe es ist ein
grundlegender konflikt auf der einen
seite haben wir ein ökonomisches system
das nur durch andauerndes wachstum
überleben kann das wachstum über alles
stellt gleichzeitig leben wir auf einem
planeten der uns zwingt den verbrauchten
natürlichen ressourcen einzudämmen
das ist ein grundsätzlicher konflikt das
ist krieg
ein krieg vor dem auch naomi klein lange
zeit die augen verschloss wie sie in
einem gleichzeitig zum buch
erscheinenden film beschreibt
länger als ich es zugeben möchte habe
ich nicht hingesehen vor dem klimawandel
die augen verschlossen habe mir
eingeredet dass es wissenschaftlich zu
komplexer als umweltschützer sich schon
drum kümmern
es war einfach nicht mein thema
erst als der hurrikan katrina 2005 new
orleans überflutete erkannten omi klein
die politischen und sozialen dimensionen
der klimakatastrophe ihre wucht trifft
auch menschen und regionen die wenig
beigetragen haben zu ihren ursachen
einfache lösungen gibt es nicht doch
warum wollte man die klimaveränderung so
lange nicht wahrhaben
der klimawandel wurde in den 1980 er
jahren die erste internationale
konferenz fand 1988 statt
man muss nur zurücklegen was damals
sonst noch geschah damals begannen
konservative politiker wie ronald reagan
in den usa und margaret thatcher in
großbritannien die grundlagen ihrer
ökonomien zu verändern
als dann der ostblock kollabierte die
berliner mauer und damit die teilung
europas vergangenheit war gab es kein
halten mehr
es begann der triumphzug dessen was man
turbo kapitalismus nennt
wer wollte da schon von erwärmung von
schmelzenden polkappen von co2
emissionen hören ein einziges modell war
vorherrschend dem jedes land der welt
folgt freie märkte und demokratie daraus
wurde das was man dann auch
neoliberalismus nannte privatisierung
deregulierung abbau staatlicher ausgaben
in meinem buch beschreibe ich den
konflikt zwischen dieser ideologie und
dem was angesichts der klimakrise
eigentlich getan werden müsste
in ihrem buch präsentierte die
ergebnisse einer fünfjährigen recherche
wissenschaftliche studien zu
erneuerbaren energien genauso wie
kritische untersuchungen heutiger
umweltpolitik im zentrum steht aber die
systemfrage ist der kapitalismus
überhaupt in der lage auf die drohende
katastrophe zu reagieren
wenn statt umzudenken anstatt komplett
in erneuerbare energien zu investieren
setzt man weiter auf den abbau fossile
brennstoffe mit fracking oder der
gewinnung von teersand wie im
kanadischen alberta soll aus der erde
auch noch der letzte tropfen öl
herausgepresst werden
exxon mobil macht 46 milliarden dollar
profit in einem jahr
diese summe ist irrational auch deshalb
regt sich widerstand an der basis und
versucht das zu tun was unsere
regierungen die offen gesagt mit dem
ölkonzern ins bett gehen eigentlich tun
sollten
in meinem land kanada ist der
unterschied zwischen industrie und
regierung nicht mehr erkennbar so
verstrickt sind sie deshalb beginnen die
leute pipelines und neuem ihn zu
blockieren auf der ganzen welt lockt die
nennt sich diese form des widerstands
gegen die verursacher der
klimakatastrophe den schleichenden tod
unseres planeten
wer dagegen kämpft sagt norman klein
kämpft auch gegen ökonomische und
soziale ungleichheit gegen die spaltung
der welt in reich und arm
doch ohne einschränkungen egal wo egal
bei wem wird die wende kaum zu schaffen
sein
wir alle stehen vor entscheidungen im
krieg zwischen klima und kapitalismus